ils sont plus d'un milliard dans le
monde à souffrir de la faim un milliard
et 20 millions de personnes exactement
précisé aujourd'hui les agences des
nations unies réuni à rome un fléau qui
gagne notre planète chaque année un peu
plus ce qui explique qu'ils s'expliquent
en 2009 par la combinaison de la crise
alimentaire et de la récession
économique
une situation intolérable et dont on
peut se débarrasser d'après les
responsables des nations unies qui tape
tous aujourd'hui du poing sur la table
régis nussbaum des oedèmes sur les pieds
les jambes
c'est l'un des symptômes de la
malnutrition cette petite fille
éthiopienne de deux ans ne pèse que 7 kg
un exemple parmi des millions du
scandale de la faim dans le monde
le constat est terrible il tient en un
chiffre un milliard d'êtres humains
souffrent de malnutrition soit 100
millions de plus que l'an dernier
c'est le chiffre le plus élevé depuis 40
ans sans surprise la malnutrition touche
principalement les régions les plus
pauvres
l'asie pacifique l'afrique subsaharienne
l'amérique latine et enfin le
proche-orient et l'afrique du nord
c'est ce qui ressort du rapport annuel
de la fao l'organisation pour
l'alimentation et l'agriculture des
nations unies
c'est catastrophique et c'est moralement
inacceptable et ce n'est pas
économiquement justifiée et nous avons
vu la paire de l'aide au développement à
l'agriculture passée de 17% en 1980 à
seulement 3,8 pour cent en 2006 alors
que 70% des pauvres vivent de
l'agriculture pour l'autoconsommation
leurs emplois et leurs revenus
résultat une envolée des prix des
denrées alimentaires de base aggravée
par la crise économique mondiale
mais il ya aussi la sécheresse qui sévit
en afrique une des pires sécheresses de
ces dernières années qui décime le
bétail et affame les populations comme
ici au kenya
dans cet hôpital le nombre d'enfants en
état de sous alimentation sévère a
beaucoup augmenté ces derniers mois
face à cette crise le g8 les huit pays
les plus riches du monde se sont engagés
en juillet dernier à apporter 20
milliards de dollars en trois ans aux
pays les plus démunis
mais il en faudrait beaucoup plus pour
commencer à inverser la tendance car on
est loin très loin de l'objectif que
s'étaient fixés les nations unies en
l'an 2000 à savoir diviser par deux le
nombre de personnes sous-alimentées
d'ici à 2015